[Musique]
sequana crois que tu as en espagne
qu'est ce que ça représentait la famille
la famille la famille d'un moment il pas
dans les rixes et comme dans maman m'a
montré ce que tu vas aller chercher le
goûteur maman bien ce qui est passé de
famille en famille mais ya pas une
bruxelles prône haïti on les appelle
akrad malanga bnia carnaval marinade de
poulet en espagne corrida de burgos que
c'est les boudins noirs de riz preuve
elle a décrit médailles et mon ruines a
partout sur la planète on trouve des
variantes le chef tigré tonnes nous
prépare d'abord le classique espagnole
aujourd'hui on va faire l'objet d'un
décret morano
comment on pourrait la décrire la crèche
et as espagnol légère croquant à comme
c'était cremo oui je vois ce que tu veux
dire ne se brise pas non c'est une
texture unique as com - le croque assure
un bon contraste pour y arriver
le chef mélange d'abord la farine le
beurre et lui ont besoin de lait tiède
pas très fort ce parce que tu ne veux
pas brûler re de l'est oui évidemment le
secret du scad la mostra une peau qui
t'ont on m'a fait dans l'allée dit me
souviens une des mains noires préférait
un super tir et de mon père fela
roquetas et lui pour fait laver chamelle
mon travail c'est d ajouter de l'eau
et beit el alami et la muscade
ok vous voulez faire la muscade et ouais
mon prix pour sa selle à la cuillère et
la poêle cac n'a fini pour eux il ajoute
le jambon à la toute fin
un repos de 24 heures au frigo est
nécessaire avant de façonner la pâte
parce que comme ça tous las cuevas
il ya de la même taille ok donc on fait
un petit bull la farine la crevette à ok
la séance d'entraînement de baseball
travail la crau guetta mais touche pas
la greta ça c'est du lait après ce sujet
tant qu une chapelure de pain va
s'aggraver d'assad a avancé un peu de
nous mêmes parce que normalement
laissons-les hier c'est un la corée 2
sec et montre que si je l'écrasé de la
boîte noire pilos com - les gens soient
trompés c'est ça le petit tour dans la
friteuse la coved à s'apprendre commencé
quand une minute
en haïti la croquette appelé marinade de
couler fait partie de la vie quotidienne
c'est le pass patauge ans crise ça c'est
vraiment la bouffe de rue comme dans mon
quartier je sais c'est qu'ils aient la
même personne qui fait ça on va aller la
farine piment fort oignons thym persil
et on ajoute que poulet déjà cuit le
chef en fait une belle pâte et la dépose
simplement dans la friteuse c'est comme
ça que je le vois même pas c'est comme
notre pays s'est servi avec peaches
depuis qu'il sait quoi c'est quand big
lycéens menace de chou et piste puis on
goûte la spécialité du chef
la cre a de maladie normale car côté
carnivores ici qu'elle était content oui
la côte est végétarien g5
ont rappelé malanga pour obtenir la
texture d'une part c'est l'amidon de ce
tubercule qui tient le tout appuyé de là
on va ajouter un mélange des pistes 1
car si oignons piments et puis ils
souffrent on va ajouter du jus d'orange
amère
ça me permet d'avoir une belle couleur
mais en couleur mais indique situant
côté d'acide aussi qu'il attaque en
bouche c'est parfait
[Musique]
moussavi
le chef toussaint nous propose aussi une
version sucrée le beignet carnaval
quoique là on garde la vague du soleil
le carnaval est fait à base de bananes
bien mais c'est plus un côté des sas est
sécurisé mais n'achètent pas marranel et
cela comme mais pour que ça commence à
devenir noir pour que le goût de la
varappe sont un peu plus et puis de là
on va jeter failli se l'est dit cabral
de soupe pour que ce après sa reprise
profite et puis c'est la vie
des gens qui voyagent poussé à réclamer
retourne en haïti à chaque saison de
carnaval
pour juments jan voss c'est ça qui me
passionne c'est ça qui nous fait
travailler parce que je dis souvent la
cuisine d'abord c'est pas seulement
nourrir le ventre ses nouvelles recrues
aussi qu'un bon
en espagne aussi les croquettes peuvent
devenir au dessert les merengues à la
licence des clubs et d'assurer avec des
sucres de cannelle et citron ça devient
le médecin préféré instantané
[Musique]